-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're hanging out with
Leslie Jones, everybody.
-Yes!
-Leslie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo! Wait a minute.
Quest, your documentary --
one of the best things
I've ever seen in my life.
-Yeah. Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
-Just wanted to say that.
-Yep.
I like when people say that.
-No, he won an Oscar.
I'm so proud.
-Oh, my God.
-I'm so proud.
He's just, like,
a little drummer here.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And he drum and he spin
those records and he said,
"I'm gonna do a documentary."
-Proud of him.
Yeah, he crushed.
-Proud of you.
-Questlove, yeah,
taking home the gold.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Taking home the gold.
We're about to play a game
called "Hey Robot."
Here we go.
-Okay.
-♪ Hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey Robot ♪
-Now, here's how this works.
This is based on a real board
game, "Hey Robot,"
that you can play at home.
It's like the classic game
"Password," okay?
But your partner
is a smart speaker.
-So you play this at
a white folks' house.
-Anyone can play this.
-No, we play spades and dominos.
And white folks play Robot.
-No, here we go.
"Hey Robot" --
here's what happens.
We're going to pick a card
with a word on it.
We're going to take turns
asking a question.
You have to get the speaker
to say that word
somewhere in the answer.
-Okay.
-If it does, you get a point.
-Okay, okay.
-Alright?
I will go first, alright?
-Okay. You gonna go first.
-Here we go.
I'll show you how it's done.
Okay.
-Okay, what's the word?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
Alright.
Whew! Alright, how do I get it
to say that?
Um, okay.
♪♪
Um...
[ Beep ]
Alexa, peanut butter and jelly
is a popular type of what?
-According to
an Alexa answers contributor,
peanut butter and jelly is
a sandwich consisting...
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I almost said
peanut butter and jelly, too.
Okay.
-You see what I'm doing?
Alexa, stop. Not bad, right?
Okay, you got this.
-First of all,
Alexa is, like, on your side.
I don't --
-Wait. We just started.
-Okay, so...
-Wait. Let's see.
-Wait a minute. How I do it?
-Yeah, that's right. Yep, okay.
You have to get it
to say "puppet."
-I gotta get it to say "puppet."
-Mm-hmm.
-Oh, so many things
coming to my head.
Uh...
Okay.
Alexa, what did Geppetto
actually intend Pinocchio to be?
-Human.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Shut up, bitch.
-Okay. Alexa, stop. Alexa, stop.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know you could make it
stop by doing that, by the way.
That's the first...
-She know what's up.
I thought it was
such an intelligent clue.
-Yeah, no, I liked your --
-But I forgot he did want him
to be human.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Can you get it?
Can you get it?
-What can I say?
-Was he...
Alexa, what was Pinocchio?
-Pinocchio
is a fictional character
and the protagonist of
the children's novel
"The Adventures of Pinocchio"
by Italian writer Carlo Collodi
of Florence, Tuscany.
Pinocchio was carved by
a wood-carver
named Geppetto
in a Tuscan village.
He was created
as a wooden puppet.
[ Dinging ]
-Yeah! They said puppet!
They said puppet!
You said puppet!
Ooh! Said puppet!
-First of all, you wouldn't
even thought of that
if I hadn't said it.
-Come on. You can't take
credit for puppet.
-I should get that point,
'cause I told you --
This is why I don't like to
play games with white people.
Okay, I go next?
-Yes.
-Okay. Come on.
What the [bleep]
What is this?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, okay.
I think -- I know what it is,
but a lot of people don't.
Okay.
Alexa, what is that thing called
that they clean the ice
on the hockey thing with?
-From reference.com,
the machine that cleans
the ice during hockey games
is called a Zamboni...
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Zamboni?! Zamboni?!
Zamboni?!
That's the hardest one
we've ever done, by the way.
Nice job!
Zamboni, first try.
-That's 2 points.
-That's 2 points
for that one, alright.
This last one, here we go.
Let's try it together
and see if we can get it.
This is 1,000 points
if we can do this.
-You know what this is.
Sum-bly.
Sublime.
-Sublime.
[ Laughter ]
Sublime.
-Sub-lime.
-Oh, okay.
Oh, I know -- I got one.
-Okay. Sublime.
-Alexa, who sings "Santeria"?
-Oh, that's cheating.
-Brad Nowell sang in
"Santeria" by Sublime.
[ Dinging ]
-That's cheating.
That's cheating.
-What are you talking about?
-And then, how'd you get
the last card?
-Wait. That was cheating?
-Cheater!
Cheater!
-Leslie Jones, everybody.
-And you did it on national TV.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Leslie -- she is guest-hosting
"The Daily Show" next week,
starting Tuesday,
and it's gonna be great.
Stick around.
We'll be right back, everybody.